we love fantasy football here and every
year we're in the celebrity fantasy
league for charity that alice in chains
and jerry cantrell holds we won it a
couple of years ago with our team name
touch of the vermeel touch of the
vermeil uh the next year man spread
centerpiece and total disaster last year
whirlpool of despair we were in a
whirlpool of despair the names come from
us throughout this show
every now and then just saying something
that sounds like a fantasy team name
brockman you jot it down write him down
and then you have about how many do we
have this year we had almost 50. so we
call it down we have to call it down
before we choose the winner yeah we got
it and by the way we don't mean us no of
course not uh every year this man does
it every year because he's a friend he's
a friend of the program he's a die-hard
moment rhymes with dench uh which is one
of his fantasy team names he loves
fantasy football he loves naming fantasy
football teams certainly his own he's an
expert at it and not even shooting the
new ant-man film in london would prevent
him from this appointed round back here
on the rich eisen show doing
what we all need him to do which is to
choose our fantasy team name is none
other than paul rudd how are you paul
hi rich
i'm uh
i'm doing really uh i'm doing great
what a
nice way of kind of describing me thank
well i mean you're you're an expert at
this paul you're you're i don't think
i'm an expert i'm not i think i don't
think i'm an expert but i do have yes on
my phone yes a similar thing that you do
which is throughout the year i'll think
oh that would be a good fantasy name and
then i keep a file
i don't know what that says about me
but i know it's not something that's
very good well it is us it's us because
sometimes i don't know if you have a
problem that we've been having all
morning calling it down we forget the
context and why we wrote it down to
begin with we forgot what it actually
meant um so what's your team name this
year wha what is your team name have you
have you come up with it paul your
teammates well i really i've really uh
slacked off on the uh getting on the
site and you know
i still am it's i'm still uh having on
in one league a holdover
and it's still a floral moment that's it
yeah now that's like a brunch place is
that what it's from like what's that a
floral moment no no that was tears of
elegance
with something that i saw
on you know like one of those real
estate shows
or like you know like open house yes and
uh they had the designer walking us
through this apartment and he was
explaining that uh in this area of the
apartment would be a wonderful place for
a floral moment
and
and uh i thought oh you mean like a
place to put some flowers there's a
create a floral moment yes and it just
it made me hate it made me hate him
so
much more
than i already hated him and i hated him
watching this show
this pretentious
designer um but the name stuck so i uh
um that's my team name i'll probably
change it out because i've been thinking
yes because i'm in london yes right now
yes um
going with
one's
favorite
colors and odors of
theater
uh all with the ou of course all the
english spelling of course
well it's an homage it's an homage paul
to your
yes
it is well it could be just colors and
odors spelled that way they could just
be that
it could be that no i used to have a
team called sounds and smells it's a
little similar to that
well if they want it you should you
should repeat so okay see this is what
we've established your credentials here
for anybody who needs to know i have a
list of eight team names i'm gonna read
two at a time you you tell me which one
you like and we'll we'll throw the other
one out and we'll keep whittling it down
till we get our our our answer how does
that work paul ryan's okay ready yeah
here's our first yep
out of the gate strong
i don't know why
this was a fan who came in and i don't
know why he was calling he was talking
about glenn close but he forgot her name
and he called her so the glenn what's
her nuts is the first one
glenn glenn what's her nuts
versus intently lovemaking
those are the two choices which one
advanced intent intently love making
um i'm gonna go with i'm gonna go with
glenn what's her name
words you probably have never said
before but okay we'll do that okay glenn
what's her nuts advances here's the next
two paul
uh tornado of bravado
that's one
and the other one i think this was
talking about uh ben roethlisberger
because he's always hurt we called him
walking ibuprofen
those are your two choices tornado of
bravado
it's it's it's walking ibuprofen
what what appeals to you absolutely yeah
tornado of bravado has two o sounds in
it at the end and that throws me off
okay so okay
so here's words i've never said before
we're halfway through glenn watts or
nuts and walking ibuprofen are still
involved
okay here's the next two
collins worth per diem which was born
out of remember he spent a week in uh
pittsburgh because that game for
thanksgiving kept
getting um
delayed so we were wondering what the
collins worth per diem is and then the
eagles just acquired a back nine joe
flacco so back nine joe flacco are your
choices paul
um
um
i don't think either one of these are
winning it but okay we could just that's
we could just eliminate it let's just
cut out the middle you don't want to
either yeah i wouldn't uh i would say if
i did if i uh if i had to if i had to uh
choose one of them i would go with the
collins okay very good uh last one last
two as this is born out of uh david
flair uh david ferrity when i was uh
doing the olympics show on peacock tokyo
gold he saw what the divers were wearing
he used the phrase plum snugglers
so plum snugglers is a choice
and then um because carson wentz could
succeed in in indianapolis the other
choice is special sauce of frank reich
those are your two choices
ooh
someone's got a little touch of the
vermeel in it
um
um
well you know let's let's uh
in
in a in a nod to the touch of a meal
we'll pick special sauce special
so here are your final four and you
could just choose your final one paul
here we go
glenn watts or nuts
walking ibuprofen
collinsworth per diem and special sauce
of frank reich those are your final
choices which is the winner which is the
team name for for us in our fantasy
league thanks to you paul rudd selecting
it what do you got um i think that for
me the clear-cut this is a clear there's
a clear-cut winner okay for me it's not
even close
well it's close okay the runner-up oh oh
my god drum roll he doesn't have a drum
roll
he's going to be is going to be glenn
what's her nothing
oh runner up he came so close i know you
guys liked it i could tell by your
reactions every time you read it
yes
yes i would choose walking ibuprofen
okay walking ibuprofen
has now
put it on there and i guess our is our
avatar is ben roethlisberger is that
what it is the problem is we don't have
him on this must be any single player
that has to play this game
maybe you should just be an avatar of a
football player okay very good walking
ibuprofen uh paul rudd you've done the
lord's work i greatly appreciate it um
have you so have you drafted yet did you
do your draft you found a space in your
shoot schedule to do your football draft
yeah yeah i did and that was also really
fun drafting at
midnight because everyone else is back
home yeah and then waking up three hours
later to go film yeah i don't advise
wow okay so who did you get do you like
it you like your team you're good
you what do you who do you got well i
mean i have more than one team
i just did too many of them um i have a
couple teams and uh but i do i do like
them actually i i know um i think
they're they're actually okay okay but
you know all right all right well you
know it's funny we had uh kind of ollie
on the show the other day in the first
seven minutes of our conversation was
about how he did the greatest parallel
park job of his life while fighting off
the rest of brooklyn to try and get the
spot literally with seven minutes of a
conversation
with kyle i think i've had that same
conversation with him
so you know exactly what it is okay well
exactly what it is i know exactly
uh he's the best bless you paul rudd
thanks for calling in rich i love it i
know you gotta run i love our little
tradition i love it i wish you luck in
the league here same to you same to you
sir cheerio with your colors and odors
and i meant everywhere yeah that's just
smashing
thanks for the call paul we'll chat soon
brother appreciate it you're the man
that's paul right everybody right there
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
legend on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here